SO MANY THINGS HAPPENED OVER THE
BREAK.
THERE WAS THE DEAL WITH THE --
WITH THE OTHER THING AND --
(LAUGHTER)
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT?
AND THEN THE BLAH BLAH WITH
THE --
(LAUGHTER)
YEAH, RIGHT, WITH THE
YOU KNOW, [ BLEEP ] THAT
[ BLEEP ].
I HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU,
(LAUGHTER)
I HAVE NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT YOU THE
WHOLE TIME!
-OF-
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
OVER THE WEEKEND, "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" GOT AHOLD OF THE FULL
2005 COSBY DEPOSITION FROM A
CASE INVOLVING A FEW OF THE AT
LEAST 48 WOMEN WHO HAVE ACCUSED
COSBY.
(IMITATING COSBY)
AND IT IS FULL OF THINGS ABOUT
THE INAPPROPRIATE, THE BLAH,
BLAH, THE BIZZAH BAZZAHS, THE
RAPING AND THE TOUCHING AND THE
DRINKING, THE BAAHHH!
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU TAKE THE
QUAALUDES, THE LAWYER ASKED HIM.
HE SAYS I USED THEM.
HE SAID, FOR WHAT?
COSBY SAID, THE SAME AS YOU
WOULD, SAY, HAVE A DRINK.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: NO, NO NO!
IT'S NOT THE SAME.
"LET'S HAVE A DRINK" ISN'T A FUN
WAY TO TELL SOMEONE YOU'RE GOING
TO RUFI THEM.
(LAUGHTER)
JUST LIKE "LET'S
HANG OUT" ISN'T A CUTESY WAY OF
SAYING YOU'RE ORGANIZING A
LYNCHING.
(LAUGHTER)
NOT THE SAME.
(IMITATING COSBY)
OKAY, SO WHAT WAS ANOTHER "COSBY
SAYS THE DARNEDEST THINGS"
THING?
(LAUGHTER)
>> SHE MEETS ME BACKSTAGE.
I GIVE HER QUAALUDES.
WE THEN HAD SEX.
THE LAWYER SAYS SHE SAID SHE
BELIEVES SHE WAS NOT IN THE
POSITION TO CONSENT TO
INTERCOURSE AFTER YOU GAVE HER
THE DRUG.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IS CORRECT?
I DON'T KNOW, COSBY REPLIED.
>> Larry: YES, YOU DO!
(LAUGHTER)
YOU GAVE HER A DRUG AND THEN HAD
SEX WITH HER!
YOU KNEW SHE COULDN'T CONSENT!
LOOK, I ONLY KNOW THREE THINGS
IN LIFE TO BE TRUE: BABY CORN
SHOULD NOT BE A THING.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT?
THE WORD "MOIST" SHOULD NEVER BE
USED EXCEPT NEXT TO THE WORD
TOWELETTE.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT?
TRUE?
AND BILL COSBY KNEW WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HE KNEW IT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT AND NOT KNOW.
(APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT?
(IMITATING COSBY)
OKAY, LET'S KEEP THIS GOING!
WHAT ELSE CRAZIEST THING IT I
-- DID I SAY?
(LAUGHTER)
>> THEN IN REGARD TO ANOTHER
JANE DOE, HE SAYS YOU BEGAN
TALKING ABOUT HER CAREER AND
ASKING ABOUT HER FATHER WHO DIED
OF CANCER.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
YES, HE SAID, I REMEMBER THAT.
>> Larry: OH, [ BLEEP ]!
NO, NO, NO.
(LAUGHTER)
PLEASE DON'T TELL ME YOU'RE
GOING TO USE THIS CANCER THING
AS A WAY TO GET HER INTO BED.
>> DID YOU ASK HER THOSE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE YOU WANTED TO
HAVE SEX WITH HER?
YES, I DID, BILL COSBY SAID.
[ AUDIENCE OHs ]
>> Larry: YOU USED HER DEAD
FATHER TO HAVE SEX WITH HER --
LITERALLY HER GHOST DAD!
(LAUGHTER)
I MEAN --
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
OKAY.
WHAT ELSE?
>> HE ALSO ADMITS IN THIS THAT
HE NEVER WENT THE ENTIRE WAY
WITH WOMEN.
THAT HE BELIEVES SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WAS CONCERNING
BECAUSE SOMEBODY COULD FALL IN
LOVE WITH HIM.
HE DIDN'T WANT THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: SO LET ME BREAK THIS
DOWN.
ACCORDING TO COSBY, WHEN YOU'RE
DRUGGING WOMEN WHO YOU'VE
SEDUCED VIA GHOST DAD CANCER
TALK, DON'T HAVE FULL-ON SEX
WITH THEM OR THEY'LL START TO
GET A LITTLE CLINGY.
(LAUGHTER)
DAMN, BILL COSBY!
WHO ARE YOU GETTING YOUR DATING
ADVICE FROM?
BILL COSBY?
(LAUGHTER)
SORRY, I COULDN'T THINK OF
ANYONE ELSE.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHAT ELSE DID THE COZ BRAG
ABOUT?
>> COSBY CLAIMED HE AND HIS
ACCUSER WERE "PLAYING SEX, WERE
PLAYING, PETTING."
>> Larry: PETTING?!
(LAUGHTER)
THAT'S GROSS.
I MEAN,
THIS ISN'T A FIELD OF CUTE
LITTLE PUPPIES, BILL.
(LAUGHTER)
BY THE WAY, YOU GUYS HAVE SAT
THROUGH A LOT OF DISGUSTING BILE
TONIGHT.
I GIVE YOU A LOT OF CREDIT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DESERVE A BREAK.
LET'S ACTUALLY SEE SOME PUPPIES
RUNNING THROUGH A FIELD.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THAT'S THE STUFF, MAN.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT.
BACK TO THE BILE.
IF THIS DEPOSITION PROVED
ANYTHING, IT'S THAT COSBY HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO SELF-AWARENESS.
>> I THINK I'M A PRETTY DECENT
READER OF PEOPLE AND THEIR
EMOTIONS IN THESE "ROMANTIC
SEXUAL THINGS," HE TOLD THE
LAWYER, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL THEM.
>> Larry: WHATEVER I WANT TO
CALL THEM IS RAPES!
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD HAVE CALLED
THEM.
HOLD ON!
AND WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU ARE A
DECENT READER OF EMOTIONS?
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS NOTHING
DECENT ABOUT YOU.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
ALL RIGHT?
AND SECONDLY,
KNOCKED-OUT-AND-SNORING IS NOT
AN EMOTION.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT.
NOW, THIS DEPOSITION WAS NOT THE
FIRST TIME COSBY BOLDLY JUST
EXPLAINED TO US WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
CHECK OUT THIS "SPANISH FLY"
ROUTINE FROM 1969.
THIS WAS FROM HIS COMEDY ACT.
>> YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
SPANISH FLY?
WELL, THERE'S THIS GIRL -- CRAZY
MARY -- YOU PUT SOME IN HER
DRINK, MAN.
SHE'S LIKE
AHHH.
(LAUGHTER)
GO TO A PARTY, SEE FIVE GIRLS
STANDING ALONE.
BOY, IN I HAD A WHOLE JUG OF
SPANISH FLY, I'D LIGHT THAT
CORNER UP OVER THERE.
[ AUDIENCE OHs ]
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: THIS WAS 15 YEARS
BEFORE "THE COSBY SHOW" WAS EVEN
ON THE AIR.
THIS WASN'T A RED FLAG.
THIS WAS A HUGE COSBY SWEATER
PATTERN FLAG.
(LAUGHTER)
RIGHT?
WAIT, HOLD ON.
(APPLAUSE)
AND EVEN ON "THE COSBY SHOW," HE
TALKED ABOUT SPIKING THE
BARBECUE SAUCE.
>> HAVEN'T YOU EVER NOTICED
AFTER PEOPLE HAVE SOME OF MY
BARBECUE SAUCE, AFTER A WHILE,
WHEN IT KICKS IN, THEY GET ALL
HUGGY-BUGGY?
>> I LOVE YOUR NECK, HONEY.
IT'S PERFECT, LIKE A SWAN.
>> OOH, ELVIN.
Larry: JESUS CHRIST, SONDRA
CAN'T EVEN KEEP HER EYES OPEN.
(LAUGHTER)
WE'VE GOT CLIFF HUXTABLE ON
CAMERA FORCING MESQUITE RUFI
SAUCE ON HIS OWN FAMILY.
(LAUGHTER)
SO LET ME SEE IF I CAN REALLY BE
CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
OKAY?
THIS IS HOW HORRIBLE OF A HUMAN
BEING THAT [ BLEEP ] IS.
THIS IS WHY I CALL HIM A
[ BLEEP ] ALL THE TIME, OKAY?
(LAUGHTER)
HE BELIEVES THAT DRUGGING AND
-- HE BELIEVES THAT DRUGGING AND
RAPING WOMEN DESERVES TO BE
LAUGHED AT.
HE PUT IT IN A COMEDY ACT, AND
HE PUT IT ON HIS TV SHOW.
HE FINDS WHAT HE DID TO BE
FUNNY.
FIVE WORDS:
YOU.
CAN.
GO.
[ BLEEP ].
YOURSELF.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)